>> Trace: BREAKING NEWS.
SUPREME COURT THAT’S THROWN A
CHALLENGE TO CALIFORNIA’S
RESTRICTIONS ON RELIGIOUS
GATHERING BACK TO THE LOWER
COURTS FOR RECONSIDERATION.
REMEMBER, THE SUPREME COURT
JUST RULED A SHORT TIME AGO IN
FAVOR OF NEW YORK SAYING THEY
COULD NOT PROHIBIT DIFFERENT
SIZES OF CROWDS AT CHURCHES.
WELL NOW WHAT THE SUPREME COURT
IS SAYING IS THEY ARE THROWING
IT BACK TO A LOWER COURT TO
HAVE THEM RECONSIDER WHETHER
THE STATE CAN DICTATE HOW BIG
CHURCH CROWDS CAN BE.
THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT
NOW MANDATES THAT THE LOWER
COURT TAKE A LOOK AT THIS AGAIN.
IT KEEPS THE MANDATE BY
CALIFORNIA IN PLACE BUT AGAIN
THIS WILL PUT IT AT THE TOP OF
THE TO DO LIST ON THE LOWER
COURTS TO GET THIS RULING OUT
IN SHORT ORDER.
WE’LL HAVE MORE ON THIS AS IT
COMES IN TO "AMERICA’S
NEWSROOM."
>> Sandra: KENTUCKY’S ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND PRIVATE CHRISTIAN
SCHOOL FILED AN EMERGENCY
REQUEST WITH THE SUPREME COURT
TRYING TO OVERTURN THE
DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR’S EXECUTIVE
ORDER TO SHUT ALL SCHOOLS DOWN.
JOINING US NOW IS ROGER BYRON,
THE ATTORNEY FOR DANVILLE
CHRISTIAN SCHOOL.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE THIS
MORNING, SIR.
SO THE KENTUCKY ATTORNEY
GENERAL IS ARGUING THAT PRIVATE
RELIGIOUS SCHOOLS SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO BE OPEN UNDER THE
GOVERNOR’S CURRENT ORDERS.
WHY?
>> THE FIRST AMENDMENT
GENERALLY REQUIRES A GOVERNMENT
TO TREAT RELIGIOUS GATHERINGS
OF PEOPLE AS WELL AS IT TREATS
OTHER GATHERINGS.
IN A COVID-19 CONTEXT THIS
MEANS THAT A GOVERNMENT CAN
ALMOST NEVER APPLY RESTRICTIONS
TO RELIGIOUS GATHERINGS THAT
DOESN’T ALSO APPLY TO OTHER
GATHERINGS.
THINGS LIKE GOING TO THE
MOVIES, SHOPPING AT A RETAIL
CENTER OR A SHOPPING MALL,
GOING TO WORK IN AN OFFICE OR
FACTORY.
ALMOST EVERYTHING IS ALLOWED IN
PERSON.
BUT PRIVATE RELIGIOUS K-12
SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN CLOSED.
>> Sandra: I ARE READ THE
LAWSUIT.
IN KENTUCKY ONE CAN CATCH A
MATINEE AT THE MOVIE THEATER.
WORK OUT AT THE GYM.
GO TO A GAMBLING PARTY AND
ATTEND A WEDDING.
A PARENT CAN SEND HIS OR HER
CHILD TO DAYCARE AND PRE-SCHOOL
AND COLLEGE STUDENTS CAN ATTEND
CLASSES BUT ALL OF KENTUCKY’S
RELIGIOUS SCHOOLS ARE SHUTTERED
THERE HAS BEEN A RESPONSE FROM
THE U.S. COURT OF APPEALS.
IT SAID THE GOVERNOR’S RULING
CAN STAND.
THE STATEMENT FROM THE GOVERNOR.
WHILE WE ALL WANT TO GET OUR
KIDS BACK TO IN-PERSON
INSTRUCTION, THE UNITED STATES
COURT OF APPEALS FOR THE SIXTH
CIRCUIT RECOGNIZED IT WOULD
ENDANGER THE LIVES OF KENTUCKY
CHILDREN, EDUCATORS AND
FAMILIES.
DO YOU FURTHER CHALLENGE WHAT
NOTION BASED ON THE FACT YOU
HAVE DR. ANTHONY FAUCI SAYING
WE HAVE TO GET THE KIDS BACK IN
SCHOOLS?
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT KIDS
ARE SPREADING THIS WHEN THEY’RE
IN THE CLASSROOM?
>> CERTAINLY.
IN KENTUCKY RIGHT NOW UNDER THE
GOVERNOR’S ORDERS THE SAME
GROUP OF PEOPLE COULD ATTEND A
FRIEND’S WEDDING AND THEN HEAD
TO THE GYM TOGETHER FOR A
WORK-OUT.
AFTERWARDS THEY COULD CATCH A
MATINEE AT THE MOVIE, THEY
COULD ATTEND A CONCERT OR AS
YOU SAID THEY COULD ATTEND A
U.K. BASKETBALL GAME WITH
THOUSANDS OF OTHER PEOPLE IF
THE ARENA AND SWING BY THE
LIQUOR STORE.
IF THEY WANTED THEY COULD GET A
TATTOO.
THEY COULD FINISH OFF THEIR
NIGHT AT THE INDOOR GAMBLING
SLOT MACHINES DOWN AT THE HORSE
TRACKS.
WHAT CAN THEY NOT DO?
THEY CANNOT ATTEND A BIBLE
CLASS AT A PRIVATE RELIGIOUS
SCHOOL.
THAT IS NOT WHAT THE FIRST
AMENDMENT REQUIRES.
>> Sandra: WE KNOW THAT JUSTICE
BRETT KAVANAUGH WHO WILL
CONSIDER THE FILING ASKED THE
GOVERNOR TO FILE A RESPONSE BY
FRIDAY.
HAS THERE BEEN ONE YET?
>> NOT TO OUR KNOWLEDGE.
WE’RE EXPECTING A RESPONSE BY
TOMORROW.
>> Sandra: KAVANAUGH CAN ACT
ALONE OR REFER THE CASE TO THE
FULL SUPREME COURT.
WE’LL BE WATCHING THIS CLOSELY.